le plus souvent concernant
la vaccination des enfants,
on a invité la D pédiatre respoe
de la prévention et du contrôle
des infections au CHU
Sainte-Justine. Dre Quach,
- Bonsoir M. Roy.
- Alors, je vais y aller
par... vraiment méthodiquement,
avec les questions qu'on reçoit
D'abord, la dose,
juste ion, on dit
que c'est à peu près le tiers
de ce en termes de quantité.
- C'est exactement le tiers,
c'est 10 5g plutôt que 30.
- Bon. Et ça, comment on est
c'était suffisant pour les
enfants, on a fait des tes
quoi?
Dre CAROLINE QUACH, pédiatre,
- On a fait, c'est pour ça
que les enfants n'ont pas été
vaccinés en même temps que les
adultes, on a fait des études
avec des groupes de 5-11 ans.
qu'on faisait, en fait,
c'est qu'on comparait
le profil de sécurité, don
qui développaient fatigue,fièvr.
La réponse immunitaire, donc,
le niveau d'anticorps qu'o à dis
dosages et l'efficacité. Et donc
quand on comparait des doses de
30 5g, en fait, ils ont cherché
la dos30, ma30, ma30, ma30, ma3u
compte qu'il y avait énormément
d'enfants qui avaient fatigue,
fièvre et tout le reste,
et avec 10, au cours des études,
ils se sont rendu compte q
non seulement c'était mieux
toléré que le 30 5g chez les
un plus faible taux d'enfants
qui avaient de l de la
fièvre et des douleurs partout,
on atteignait le même n même n u
d'anticorps et qu'en boutcacitéa
mêdose de 30 5g chez
les plus vieux. Donc, on y varse
fficace possible.
- Bon. Et commees adultes,
andera deux doses.
- Oui, tout à fait.- Parce que e
contre la COVID.Une dose n'aura.
- Parce qu'on voit entre autres
à cause du variant Delta qu'une
dose n'est pas complètement
protectrice, c'est-à-dire
que chez les plus vieux, on a
une protection autour de 30 %,
mais qu'à 2 doses, on monte
au-delà de 80 % contre
infections symptomatiques.
Donc, ça prend la deuxième dose
pour solidifier
immunitaire.
- Je vous pose la question qu'on
reçoit les plus "J'ai des crainx
effetses possibles possibles po"
Beaucoup de gens disent ça. Pour
mais pas trop. Mais pour les
enfants, oh, on a des craintes
- C'est compréhensible par
pour les enfants, on le dit la
sévère, ça prend un profil desé.
Maintenant, on voit que avec les
vaccinés dans les études de
phase trois, on a suffisamment
de pression pour évaluer lese,
douleurs locales, etc. on voit
que de ce côté-là, y'a pas de
problème. Je
fait peur aux gens c'est des
complications un peu plus rares
mais qui pourrai
grave; par exemple les
myocardiques qu'on a rapportés
chez l
30 ans. Ce qu'on voit dans les
myocardiques, c'est que 90 % de
c'est-à-dire qu'un peu d'Advil
au Tylenol, repos et ça s'en va.
chez les 16-17 ans que chez les
12 à 15 ans. Donc l'âge a l'air
Il n'y a pas de séquelles et qui
a des données émergentes qui
quand on espace l'intervalle
entre les dose, donc au lieu de
le manufacturier le recomm
mais qu'on fait plutôt du huit
Canada depuis le début, hu
plus, il semble y avoir moins de
profil de sécuri
même assez bon, c'est-à-dire que
d'un point de vucomplications sa
moins eux,
on peut s'attendre il y a moins
de myo
élément, c'est que ces
nnent en général
après la deuxième dose et que
vaccinés il y a déjà deux
es, qu'apres, qu'apres, qu'apree
dose on a rien vu et qu'ils vont
trois semaines,
nous qu'on va être rendus à huie
qu'on va
avoir quand même les signaux
- Donc vous rassurer de manière
non équivoque les parents,
en disant ça.
- Oui, pas de signal qui vienne
des États-Unis et par ailleurs
on fait une surveillance qui se
continue. Vous l'avez vu au
vaccination, quand on avait un
doute que ce soit sur les
thromboses post AstraZeneca ou
que ce soit les myocardiques, il
été lancé, s'il fallait fa
des changements dans les
ont été faits.
- D'accord, donc on ne cache
des cr'agit
d'un nouveau vaccin." Ça,
- Oui,ccin
plus ou moins. Ça fait quandu'os
onnes sur la
planète avec le triple de laoins
nouveau vaccin e
ait autant d'utilisation d'un
vaccin avec un smême très bien .
Les sy
sont en place; donc c'est
un noufait un an, mais c'est mon
nouvean an.
Je pense qu'il faut prendre ça
comme données et la surveillance
- L'expérience a été faite à
multiplié les doses. Là, c'ests.
Vous avez fait mention de sa
beaucoup. Les gens disent :
"Je ne vois pas l'utilité parce
la COVID ne sont pas élevé
pour mes enfants."
la vaccination de l'enfant
c'est au-delà... il y a une
91 % d'efficacit
a une protection. Il n'en
y avoi
il va y avoir de transmission oa
e
transmission communautaire qu'on
place. Je pense que les gens onn
arriver à ça, on n'a pasix que i
peuvent le transmettre.Présentùx
d'infection, ça demeure
groupe n'est pas vacciné. Et àfe
la transmission dans la famille
vers les plus jent
hospitalisés parce qu'ils l'onts
les plus vieux qui sont plus
fragilnc, ça ajoute
des barrières de prote
ceux qui sont plus vulnérables.
- Donc, quand Monsieur Legaultce
la vaccination d
que ça va me permettre, début
2022, a-t-il dit, de revenir à
d'accord avec ça? C'est un
élémen
la protection collective que de
faire vacciner nt un élément im.
Mainte tous tous tous tous touss
les gens, qui jusqu'à
vacciner, qui sont adultes
e-là.
Je pense que ça va dans les deux
on a de couvertu
plus on est plus près de
les me
qu'un nouveau variant arrivera
instant,
avec le delta, c'est ce quide l.
- Je vous laisse
avant, l'Autriche; on parlait à
quelqu'un en Autriche plus tôt.
vaccination que le Canada parex.
c'est la même population qu'au
15 000 par jour.
vous inquiète? Est-ce que vous
croyez que ça pedans votre anals
pays en Europe? l'impression que
couverture vaccinale moindre,let
.
L'Europe a quand même relâché
plus allègre depuis l'été, cefa.
Cela contribue à l'augmentation.
d'essayer de maintenir lesions s
pour qu'on puisse à Noël se voir
Noël parce qu'on le sait; à Noët
intergénérationnel,
interrégions. S'il y a de
transmission qui va y avoirlieur
lieu. Si on part avec un taux
d'infection plus bas, qu'il y a
moins de gens qu
potentiellement contagieux,
il va y avoir moins de
transm
des fêtes.
- Donc, l'exemple de l'Autriche
n'arrivera pas nécessairement
ici. On est mieux protégés, onÇt
pas dire que c'est là-bas, que
ça va arriver dans trois
semaines ici.nécessairement. Mae
veut pas dire non plus qu'on est
sortis de l'auberge parce qu'on
a une couverture vaccinale à pet
tout maintenant, c'est possible
que ça remonte. Ce qu'on ne veut
pas voir, c'est l'augmentationdt
par une augmentation
des hospitalisations.
- Docteur Quach, très clair.
Merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé.
- Merc